[Music]
now we've brokered missing pieces when
you're digging yourself out of the
ground I don't know if you noticed but I
kind of got some like uma Thurman killed
bill by when he were reading this script
what did you think when you're like oh
my goodness she's pregnant and she's
dealing with all of this for me this was
my interaction hero coming out I was
like give it to me where's my Rambo
moment please like let me kick some butt
let me have a fight scene it was all
that this is like an actor's dream you
know right so like have stuns and have
action and be badass were you prepared
for stunts like that I was able to
actually do what I could do you know
they did actually bury me alive being my
son mm-hmm but there's the magic of
cinema
you know it's an illusion that's one
thing I love so much about doing stunts
is you can create this facade but they
kept us safe good good what did you
think when you finally watch as we were
watching it my whole family's like
looking at me like journey you you
actually did this hunter and like they
were shouting and then I was looking at
like this Rosalee look at yourself you
almost died we do see that you and Noah
are going to reunite but Rosalee is kind
of already to the next phase of her plan
yeah what are we gonna see as far as
that dynamic coming up in a few episodes
we'll see this friction build in the
because there's a theme in our this
season of the show citizen versus
soldier you know where do you stand on
the battlefield
no one's been a soldier his entire life
right Rosalie has recently come into her
warrior hood you know and she is a
soldier now and so he's ready to put the
fight down and build a life with her and
she's not at that point because her
mother her brothers those that she loves
are still in bondage and for her she's
not really free until they're free you
make ourselves free by the choices we
make there's no we're ready to settle
down and be a father are we gonna see
that like that push from him to focus
more on you guys in your family well
here's the thing no it doesn't you're
not aware of the pregnancy yet so we
shall see you know I wouldn't have been
able to say it that's just all I'm gonna
say whoa drops the bomb I'm ready for
the bone to be dropped on that one
[Music]